WELCOME BACK ONLY RETURNING
MEMBERS ADVICE YOUR PHONE
I WANT TO WELCOME OUR NEW
MEMBERS -- TO THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
SO MEMBER GRAYSON BIGELOW
CUNNINGHAM DEEP -- ONLY MEMBERS
TO THE COMMITTEE WELCOME LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU AS DOES
A SO ASSEMBLYMEMBER VICE CHAIR
FONG WE'VE GROWN FROM FOURTEEN
TO FIFTEEN MEMBERS ALSO WELCOME
TO OUR NEW COMMITTEE OUR
NEW SECRETARY CARLA MENDOZA
WHO'S JOINING US -- WILL BE
DEALING WITH A LOT OF ISSUES
THIS YEAR ONE OF MY BIGGEST
PRIORITIES IS PROTECTING
THE INTEGRITY OF SB ONE
NOTHING GETS IN FRONT OF SB ONE
TWO YEARS FOUR MONTHS AND SIX
DAYS IT TOOK TO GET THE BILL
SO SIGNED BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR AND
SO I WON NOBODY THINKS THAT
ANYBODY IS GOING TO MESS WITH
IT THANK YOU FOR THAT MR FUNG
DO YOU WANNA MAKE ANY COMMENTS
SO GREAT LET'S GET STARTED
-- MASSACRING ONE CULTURAL
FRAZIER HERE ÓNG AGUIAR-CURRY
BERMAN BIGELOW CHIP
CUNNINGHAM DALY DEEP
HERE FRIEDMAN GIPSON
GRAYSON
MEDINA NAZARIAN O'DONNELL
WE HAVE NINE WILL HAVE A QUORUM
ALL KLAY VIA ROLLED AND FOR HOW
TO MEMBERS -- WE CAN MOVE ON
TO ADOPTION OF COMMITTEE RULES
DO WE HAVE A MOTION OF A MOVIE
OF MOTION BY MISTER KANSEN
CHU SECOND BY MISTER BERMAN
-- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE MOTION TO ADOPT
THE COMMITTEE ROLES FRAZIER
FONG AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN
BIGELOW CHIU CUNNINGHAM DALY
DEEP FRIEDMAN GIPSON GRAYSON
MEDINA IS THERE IN O'DONNELL
THE COMMISSION RULES HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED I WILL MOVE ON TO --
ANNOUNCEMENTS WILL MEASURES
ON CONSENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB TWENTY ONE OBERNOLTE
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB ONE
FIFTY EIGHT VOEPEL FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB FIVE TO FIFTY
TWO DAILY FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB THREE ONE THREE FRAZIER
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT ACR FOR
FRAZIER FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
IS YOUR AC OR SEVENTEEN IRWIN
SO AT THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO THE COMMITTEE HELLO
DR EMOTIONAL CONSERVE OUR FILE
SAID MR XU AND MR GIPSON
PERSONAL SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY WILL CALL THE
ROLL CONSENT ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE
FONG FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
BERMAN BERMAN AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE CHIU OKAY -- I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
DAILY DAILY I DEEP I DEEP
I FRIEDMAN GIPSON HI GIPSON
AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
MEDINA THIS AREA O'DONNELL
NEW
SO THE CANCEL CONCERT
CALENDARS OUT SO WE MOVE ON
TO THIS MAY BUSINESS WHEN I
FIRST CALLED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DEEP AB THREE ONE SEVEN MR
DAILIES ASKED TO BE CHANGED
IN YOUR IS YOUR WITNESS HERE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TRY TO
OKAY THAT'S WHY WE DID
THAT MR DEEP WE PLEASE
-- MOVE TO PUT IN PLACE
CONVERSELY WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND --
MEMBERS OF FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY -- -- THINKING OUR
CHAIRMAN AS WELL AS -- VICE
CHAIR OF FOR A CO SPONSORING
-- THIS BILL -- AB THREE
SEVENTEEN WILL PROHIBIT A
PRIVATE ENTITY FROM SELLING
ANY APPOINTMENTS ISSUE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
BY TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA
DRIVER LICENSE WILL HAVE TO
BE REAL ID COMPLIANCE IN ORDER
TO BORE A DOMESTIC FLIGHT THIS
REQUIRE AN IN PERSON VISIT
WITH MULTIPLE DOCUMENTS OF
ID AND PROOF OF RESIDENCY A
COMPANY IN CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
SELLING CORN QUOTE EXPEDITED
APPOINTMENTS TO CUSTOMER TO
GUARANTEE APPOINTMENTS WITH
THE DMV WITHIN TWO TO THREE
WEEKS THEIR EMPLOYEES SCOURED
THE DMV WEBSITE LOOKING FOR
APPOINTMENTS AND IN BOOK THOSE
APPOINTMENTS UNDER A CUSTOMER'S
NAME BY CHARGING THEM A FEE
THIS COMPANY IS PROFITING
OFF OF A FREE SERVICE THAT
IS PROVIDED THROUGH ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS IF THIS INEQUITY
IS NOT FIXED THE CURRENT
SYSTEM ALLOWS THOSE WITH THE
MEANS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
OF A SYSTEM THAT IS SUPPOSED
TO SERVE CALIFORNIANS FROM
ALL ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS
THIS AFFECTS THOSE IN OUR
STATE WHO MAY BE ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED AND WHO CANNOT
AFFORD TO PAY FOR THE COST
FOR THESE APPOINTMENTS IT IS
INEQUITIES NOT SOLVE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE GREATER RESOURCES THE
GERMAN WILL BE GIVEN GREATER
ACCESS TO A FREE GOVERNMENT
SERVICE AT THANK YOU AGAIN
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MISS A VICE
CHAIR OF FOR A CO AUTHORING
THIS MEASURE AND I THINK YOU
-- AND I THINK THE MEMBER OF
FOR THE TIME I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SOMEONE GIVE MISTER FUNG JEFF'S
COMMENTS I'LL BE VERY BRIEF
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS THANK YOU
SOMETHING MEMBER DEEP -- AND
MEMBERS THE CALIFORNIA BERMAN
OF MOTOR VEHICLES IS THE
ONE STATE AGENCY THAT EVERY
RESIDENT IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA
IS REQUIRED TO VISIT IN PERSON
THERE ARE OPERATIONS THAT
ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
SYSTEM BY LOCKING DOWN ALL THE
APPOINTMENTS AND SELLING THEM
TO TAXPAYERS AT A PREMIUM WHAT
WE HAVE SEEN SIMILAR BUSINESS
MODELS FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO
PURCHASE THE LATEST I PHONE
FOR HIGH DEMAND OR FOR HIGH
DEMAND TICKETS FOR CONCERTS
A CONSUMER STILL HAVE THE
OPTION TO CHOOSE WHETHER THEY
WANT TO PAY A PREMIUM TO MAKE
THIS PURCHASE THE RESIDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY DO
NOT HAVE A CHOICE WITH THE DMV
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO VISIT THE
DMV LONG WAIT TIMES INCLUDED
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SEVENTEEN
ENSURES FAIRNESS FOR TAXPAYERS
SO THEY DO NOT HAVE TO PAY FOR
A GOVERNMENT SERVICE ALLOWING
ENTITIES TO TAKE UP THE BULK
OF THE AVAILABLE APPOINTMENTS
LEAVES MANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO NEED TO MAKE AN URGENT
APPOINTMENT IN A VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION IF THEY HAVE TO PAY
A THIRD PARTY TO GET EMPLOYMENT
THAT IS NOT THREE MONTHS DOWN
THE LINE AB THREE SEVENTEEN
MAKES THIS SIMPLE FIX FOR
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHO
ARE ALREADY DEALING WITH MANY
HEADACHES WHEN IT COMES TO THE
DMV I ASK FOR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
WRONG ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SEVENTEEN
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
OTHER YOU'RE REPRESENTING
HIM STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF ALL STATE INSURANCE
IN SUPPORT THANKS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT WITH THE
TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
HI MARIA GARCIA WITH CREAMER
TRACK ON BEHALF OF STATE FARM
INSURANCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB THREE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE TYPE OF THE
LIKELY STATE YOUR NAME AND
-- WE REPRESENTING PLEASE
GOOD AFTERNOON -- KATHY
SURE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA -- ARE ONLY
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE
SEVENTEEN IS THE CREATION
OF A NEW CRIME A MISDEMEANOR
UNDER THIS CRIME -- WE TAKE NO
POSITION ON WHETHER THE PRIVATE
SALE OF DMV APPOINTMENTS SHOULD
BE ALLOWED UNDER LAW BUT WE
DO BELIEVE IT IS UNNECESSARY
AND UNWISE TO CREATE IMPOSE
CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR THIS
BEHAVIOR OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS ALREADY OVER BURDENED
CREATION OF A NEW CRIME WILL
ADD TO THE STRESS ON THE
SYSTEM ADDING NEW CASES TO BE
TRIED IN CRIMINAL COURT AND
POTENTIALLY EVEN ADDITIONAL
INDIVIDUALS SENTENCED TO
JAIL TIME -- ALL THIS IS
UNNECESSARY TO THE TO ACHIEVE
THE GOAL OF STOPPING THIS
PRACTICE IF THE SALE OF DEAL
AT DMV APPOINTMENTS AS MADE
UNLAWFUL AND SUBJECT TO CIVIL
PENALTIES VIOLATIONS WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO CALIFORNIA'S UNFAIR
COMPETITION LAW BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE SEVENTEEN
TWO HUNDRED IT SEEK -- THE AG
AND COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
WOULD BE AUTHORIZED UNDER
THAT LAW TO -- TO TO -- TO
STOP THE PRACTICE INCLUDING
BOTH INJUNCTIVE RELIEF AND
-- MONETARY PENALTIES -- I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DEEP AND HIS STAFF FOR --
LISTENING TO OUR CONCERNS AND
WORKING WITH US AND WE HOPE
WE ARE ABLE TO RESOLVE THANK
YOU FOR THAT ANY OTHER MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE SEVENTY
SEEING NONE LIKE CLOSE
OF THE SERMON WILL WE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ENABLE
THANK YOU SIR ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE AUTHORS OF FROM THE GREAT
SELECT AND THEN MISTER BIGELOW
FIRST IN MISTER DALEY'S SECOND
MOVING FOR WILL -- I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
MY STAFF ON THIS BILL -- DMV
HAS A LONG WAY TO GO REDUCING
WAIT TIMES AS WE KNOW IN THE
MEANTIME WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE AN APPOINTMENT ALONE
COMPANIES TO BE ABLE TO SELL
THESE APPOINTMENTS PROVIDES A
PERVERSE INCENTIVE AND DENIES
CALIFORNIA'S EQUAL ACCESS TO
THE DMV IT'S IMPORTANT OF THIS
BEHAVIOR IT BE MADE ILLEGAL
AND NOT JUST A CIVIL ASSESSMENT
THAT CAN BE FACTORED INTO THE
COST OF DOING BUSINESS I AM
HAPPY BECAUSE HIS BILL WITH
YOU IN REQUEST RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE FROM THE
COMMITTEE FOR MISTER DEEDS
BILLINGS REFORMS GOOD JOB
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ONE EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER AYE FRAZIER AYE FONG
FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW
AYE CHU CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I DAILY DAILY I DEEP
I DEEP I FRIEDMAN GIPSON R.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA MEDINA
AYE NAZARIAN O'DONNELL
WE'LL LEAVE THIS OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS I WILL MOVE ON
TO MR DALY HAS YOUR WHEN THEY
SHOWED OR WOULD YOU PREFER OKAY
PLEASE STEP THE PODIUM AND
START WHEN YOU'RE READY SIR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF MY WITNESSES ARE
PRESENT -- THIS BILL CONCERNS
DISTRACTED DRIVING WHICH AS
MOST OF US UNDERSTAND CAN BE AS
DEADLY AS IMPAIRED DRIVING --
FOR WE'VE INTRODUCED THIS BILL
TO IMPROVE SAFETY ON OUR ROADS
THE BILL WILL STRENGTHEN THE
PENALTY FOR DISTRACTED DRIVING
TO INCLUDE A POINT VIOLATION
ON A PERSON'S DRIVING RECORD
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THE DRIVERS
WHO TEXT MESSAGE WHILE DRIVING
ARE EIGHT TIMES AS LIKELY TO
BE IN AN ACCIDENT OR A NEAR
ACCIDENT AS DRIVERS WHO ARE
NOT TEXTING UNFORTUNATELY OUR
EXISTING DISTRACTED DRIVING
LAWS HAVE NOT DONE ENOUGH TO
DETER THIS DANGEROUS PRACTICE
FOR EXAMPLE THE DMV REPORTS
THAT IN THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND
AND SIXTEEN THERE WERE NEARLY
TWO HUNDRED NINE THOUSAND SUCH
OFFENSES TICKETS GIVEN OUT
THE NUMBER JUMPED TO TWENTY
PERCENT THE FOLLOWING YEAR
THOSE THE MOST RECENT STATS
SO AFTER THAT TWENTY PERCENT
JUMP THERE WERE TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
TICKETS HANDED OUT IN THE YEAR
TWENTY SEVENTEEN CLEARLY THE
CURRENT PENALTIES -- WHICH
ARE QUITE SMALL A BASE FINE
OF TWENTY DOLLARS FOR FIRST
VIOLATION AND FIFTY DOLLARS
FOR SUBSEQUENT VIOLATIONS
HAVE HAD LITTLE IMPACT ON
THIS DANGEROUS PRACTICE BY
ELEVATING DISTRACTED DRIVING
CITATIONS TO THE SAME STATUS
AS OTHER DANGEROUS DRIVING
VIOLATIONS SUCH AS SPEEDING
OR RUNNING A RED LIGHT THE
MEASURE WILL HELP MAKE ROADS
SAFER FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
WITH ME TODAY OUR MIKE KNUDSEN
ON BEHALF OF THE AUTOMOBILE
CLUB OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND JONATHON FELDMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION MISTER
KNUDSEN DO YOU WANT TO PROCEED
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF MY
NEEDS IN HERE ON BEHALF OF
-- TRIPOLI AUTOMOBILE CLUB OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE ARE --
ARGUABLY THE LARGEST TRAFFIC
SAFETY ORGANIZATION IN THE
STATE -- WE ARE THE SPONSORS
OF THE MEASURE -- THIS IS BASED
ON OUR RESEARCH IS ONE OF THE
SINGLE MOST DANGEROUS THINGS
THAT HAPPENS ON OUR HIGHWAYS
WE THINK SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE
ABOUT DONE ABOUT IT -- IT IS
A SERIOUS AND GROWING PROBLEM
IF YOU DRIVE AT ALL AND YOU
LOOK TO THE LEFT OR LOOK TO THE
RIGHT YOU WILL SEE SOMEBODY ON
THEIR PHONE UNLESS OF COURSE
YOU'RE ON YOURS THEN YOU MAY
NOT SEE IT BUT -- IT'S A IT'S
A HUGE PROBLEM -- IT'S GETTING
WORSE IT'S UNDER REPORTED
-- AND POINTS MATTER -- WE
NEED TO WE NEED TO CHANGE THE
NARRATIVE WE NEED TO -- CHANGE
THE CULTURE JUST LIKE WE DID
WITH DO YOU EYES AND CONTINUE
TO TRY TO DO JUST LIKE WE DID
WITH SEAT BELTS WE NEED TO
WE NEED TO START SENDING THE
A PROPER MESSAGE THIS IS AN
OUTLIER IN TERMS OF -- UNSAFE
DRIVING ACTIVITY THAT DOESN'T
GET A POINT AND WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO HARMONIZE THE LAW --
DO SOMETHING ABOUT THIS VERY
DANGEROUS THING -- WE BELIEVE
THAT IT WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE ACCIDENTS INJURIES
AND DEATHS AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE STATEMENT
WE REPRESENT CHAIR MEMBERS
JONATHON FELDMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION -- PLEASE USE
ONE OF THE PRIMARY GROUP THAT
SUPPORTED AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE FROM TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THAT FIXED LOOPHOLES IN OUR
CURRENT DISTRACTED DRIVING
LAWS THAT WERE ALLOWING PEOPLE
ACTUALLY USE THEIR PHONES
WHILE DRIVING AND ALTHOUGH
WE FIX THAT LOOPHOLE AND IT'S
OUR LAWS CLEAR NOW YOU CAN'T
HOLDEN OPERATE YOUR PHONE
WHILE DRIVING -- IT'S STILL
AN EFFECTIVE IN DETERRING THIS
DANGEROUS BEHAVIOR AND THAT'S
A THAT'S A PROBLEM THIS BILL
IS TRYING TO ADDRESS AND IT
IS A DANGEROUS BEHAVIOR I MEAN
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE YOU
KNOW THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
PROBABLY NOTED THAT -- LOOKING
AWAY FROM THE ROAD IT FOR FIVE
SECONDS WHILE DRIVING AT FIFTY
FIVE MILES AN HOUR THE SAME
THING IS GOING BLIND FOLDED --
FOR THE LENGTH OF A FOOTBALL
FIELD I DON'T THINK ANYONE
OF US WOULD DO THAT NO BLIND
FOR THEMSELVES WHILE DRIVING
FIFTY FIVE MILES AN HOUR BUT
TOO MANY OF US DO THAT -- SAME
BEHAVIOR BY TEXTING AND LOOKING
AT THE PHONE WHILE DRIVING
-- AND IT'S A GROWING PROBLEM
THE LA TIMES LAST YEAR IN AN
ARTICLE -- TITLED TEXTING WHILE
DRIVING IS AS DANGEROUS AS
DRUNK DRIVING AND WE NEED TO
TREAT IT ACCORDINGLY -- FOUND
THAT TEXTING IS THE MOST COMMON
FORM OF DISTRACTED DRIVING
AND TEAMS ARE PARTICULARLY
AT RISK FOUR TIMES MORE
LIKELY THAN OLDER DRIVERS
TO BE DISTRACTED BY THEIR
CELL PHONES WHILE DRIVING --
VIOLATIONS FOR DRIVING ARE
VIOLATIONS FOR DR -- USING
A CELLPHONE CARE THE LOWEST
BASE FIND FOR ANY VIOLATION
OF THE VEHICLE CODE WAS ALSO
POINTED OUT YOUR NOW SAYS
AND IF THIS IS AS SERIOUS AS
A PROBLEM AS WE ALL BELIEVE
IT IS AS THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS RESEARCHERS --
IN STUDIES APPOINTED TO BE YOU
KNOW IT'S TIME THAT WE ACTUALLY
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT IN THIS
BILL TAKES AN APPROPRIATE
STEP TOWARDS REDUCING THE
INJURIES AND FATALITIES
FROM THIS BEHAVIOR SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANKS FOR THIS POSITION IN NEW
REPRESENT PLEASE MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE JAMES
OF ART OF BEHALF OF A PAID A
CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE RIGHTS
AND SAFETY ORGANIZATION AND
IT'S VERY DANGEROUS FOR US
HAVING NO PROTECTION RUNNER
MOTORCYCLES WHEN CARS IF YOU'RE
INTO OUR LANE BECAUSE THEY'RE
TEXTING ON THEIR PHONES WE
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU
-- ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC STILL LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF YESTERDAY
WAS BILL IS THE CHAIR I
MEMBERS COMMITTEE OUR MONTHLY
SOUND ON THE AFTER AMERICAN
PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THE BILL
A MEDICAL DRAMA
SENTRY INSURANCE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL
NEW ME THE DRONE WITH MY Q.
CUT CAN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF
OF THE PACIFIC ASSOCIATION
OF DOMESTIC INSURANCE
COMPANIES IN SUPPORT
REGARDS THE ON THE HAVE A STATE
FARM INSURANCE AND SUPPORT
CAN STONE STONE ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF ALL STATE
INSURANCE IN SUPPORT THANKS
SYLVIA SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
MUNICIPAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION
IT IS IN LINE WITH OUR LOCAL A
DISTRACTED DRIVING OUT REACHING
CAMP EDUCATION IN CAMPAIGN
EFFORTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
ALSO SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
NO WILL GO TO ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO LIKE TO TESTIFIED
OPPOSITION TO MR DAILIES BILL
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP RIGHT
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS
IN THE MOUTH MADE A TRANSIT
UNION -- FIRST I'D LIKE TO YOU
-- RECOGNIZED MISTER DALY'S
INTEREST AND AND YOUR INTEREST
IN THIS BILL -- I THINK THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO START BY SAYING
THAT WE OBVIOUSLY RECOGNIZE
IT'S A SERIOUS PROBLEM -- OUR
DRIVERS YOU KNOW THEY SPEND AN
INORDINATE AMOUNT OF TIME ON
THE ROADS THEY SHARE THE ROADS
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE TAKING PART
IN THIS DANGEROUS BEHAVIOR
-- THAT SAID WE ARE TAKING AN
OPPOSING LESS AMENDED POSITION
WE LIKE TO SEE THE BILL -- TAKE
A BIT OF A MORE INCREMENTAL
APPROACH WITH THERE BEING A
FINE FOR THE FIRST OFFENSE IN
A POINT ON EACH SUBSEQUENT --
EVENT THERE AFTER -- ABOUT TEN
YEARS AGO WE BOUGHT BROUGHT
STATE LINE TO CONFORMITY WITH
FEDERAL LAW AND -- A POINT
ON YOUR PERSONAL LICENSE ALSO
AFFECTS YOUR COMMERCIAL LICENSE
-- SO WE'RE NOT WORRIED ABOUT
OUR GUYS WHEN THEY'RE DRIVING
IN THEIR COMMERCIAL VEHICLE
WHERE IT'S OF INSTANT FIREBALL
FENCE IT'S WHAT HAPPENS IN
THE WEEKEND -- WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THEY'RE IN THEIR PERSONAL
TIME -- AND AND I THINK THAT
A LOT OF A LOT HAS BEEN MADE
ABOUT TRAFFIC SAFETY SCHOOL AND
HOW YOU CAN YOU GO TO TRAFFIC
SCHOOL GET THE POINT EXPUNGED
-- ALL THAT CONSIDER YOU CAN
ONLY GO ONCE EVERY EIGHTEEN
MONTHS SO IF YOU GET AT A
POINT IN THE FIRST MONTH FOR
LET'S SEE SPEEDING AND THEN YOU
GET A CELL PHONE USAGE IN THE
SECOND MONTH -- YOU CAN GET AT
POINT ON YOUR PERSONAL LICENSE
YOU WILL GO TODAY IT WOULD IT
WOULD AFFECT YOUR COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE RATES CAUSES THE THAT
THAT -- THE SHARP INCREASE IN
I'M WE'VE HAD MEMBERS WHO HAVE
BEEN FIRED AFTER DRIVING FOR
THIRTY YEARS AND SO -- WE WE
RECOGNIZE IT'S A BIG PROBLEM
BUT WE WE FAVOR LIKE I SAID
THE INCREMENTAL APPROACH I
THINK WE WOULD -- LIKE TO SEE
-- WHETHER IT'S YOU KNOW IF
WE CAME BACK AND REVISIT IT
WOULD HAVE A -- WOULD HAVE
A QUANTIFIABLE I'M YOU KNOW
DECREASE IN THIS BEHAVIOR
WILL WE BE I'M JUST RAISING
PREMIUMS ON PEOPLE SO THANK YOU
THERE'S NOT AN INCREMENTAL
APPROACH TO DEATH SO
I JUST WANNA LET YOU
KNOW THAT MR DAILY --
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
AGAINST THE AUTHORS BILL
-- ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR OF THE COMMITTEE
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR
-- BEING A JOINT AUTHOR AND
ELECTED TO POINT THAT OUT TO
TO HIGHLIGHT EVEN THOUGH IT
IS IN THE PAPER WORK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR --
I HAVE A LONG STANDING VERY
RESPECTFUL HEALTHY RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE TEAMSTERS UNION
AND -- INCLUDING THE GUY WHO
USED TO BE USED TO BE SITTING
THERE IN THAT CHAIR AND HIS
-- NOW OFF WRITING NOVELS OR
SOMETHING BUT -- -- ALL ALL
CONTINUE TO WORK -- -- IN GOOD
FAITH WITH THE TEAMSTERS --
SERIOUS MATTER OF ONE'S JOB
ONE'S LIVELIHOOD WE TAKE THAT
SERIOUSLY I TAKE IT SERIOUSLY
BUT CERTAINLY THIS PROBLEM
WHICH APPEARS TO BE A GROWING
PROBLEM IF WE LOOK AROUND OVER
ON A ON A FREEWAY OR A HIGHWAY
OR EVEN ON A CITY STREET YOU
SEE FOLKS WITH THEIR HEADS
DOWN AND IT'S IT'S STARTLING
IN ITS IT'S SCARY AND IT'S
APPALLING AND IT'S DANGEROUS
AND -- WE HAVE TO JUST TAKE
STEPS TO TRY TO -- -- MAKE A
BIGGER DEAL OUT OF THE OUT OF
THE PROBLEM AND -- SO ALL KEEP
TALKING TO THE OPPONENTS OF
THE OPPONENT AND -- AND KEEP
AN OPEN MIND AND -- -- THAT
PRESS FORWARD BECAUSE IT'S SO
I THINK THIS IS PART OF OUR
JOB I REALLY DO AND THAT'S --
I TAKE THIS SUBJECT SERIOUSLY
AND WE HAVE GOOD SPONSORS SO
WITH THAT -- ARE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER DALY AND THANK YOU FOR
PICKING UP THIS BILL IS HERE
I THINK I DID IT THREE TIMES
SO FAR HEADING KNOWLEDGE IN AS
YOU MENTIONED THE INFRACTION
TWENTY AND FIFTY DOLLARS FOR
THE SECOND OCCURRENCE YOU LOOK
AT THE AMOUNT OF TICKETS THE
HIGHWAY PATROL'S WRITING AT
TWELVE THOUSAND TICKETS A MONTH
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE THOUSAND
OFFICERS DOWN IN THE HIGHWAY
PATROL STATEWIDE SO COULD THEY
BE MORE EFFECTIVELY USED IF
PEOPLE WORK BREAKING THE LAW
IN THIS MATTER AND IT WAS A
LARGER DETERRENT SO THAT HE
WOULDN'T DO THIS -- YOUR OWN
AGAIN TWENTY FIFTY AND IT'S
A THOUSAND DOLLARS TO LEADER
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IF YOU THROW SOMETHING OUT OF
YOUR WINDOW IN YOUR CAR I'M
NOT SEEING THE EQUITY IN IN IN
A DETERRENT THERE IN THIS AND
AS I MENTIONED I DON'T THINK
THERE'S AN INCREMENTAL WAY
TO DEATH I -- AS A FATHER WHO
LOST A CHILD IN A CAR ACCIDENT
NOT DUE TO DISTRACTED DRIVING
BUT KNOWING THE CONSEQUENCES
SO I REALLY FIRMLY BELIEVE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND PROPERLY TREATS THIS
OFFENSE IS A MINOR INFRACTION
IN FACT THE TICKET FOR
DISTRACTED DRIVING WHO KILLS
OVER THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE
ANNUALLY AS LOW AS POSSIBLE
PENALTY IN THE VEHICLE CODE
THIS IS THE WRONG MESSAGE TO
CALIFORNIA DRIVERS ANY DRIVERS
OF ANY KIND OF VEHICLE ADDING
A POINT WILL HELP DISCOURAGES
DANGER DAYS BEHAVIOR IS NOT
TO BE PUNITIVE IT'S TO BE
A DETERRENT WE'RE NOT USING
THIS AS A SLEDGE HAMMER TO
STOP PEOPLE FROM DOING WE WANT
THEM TO BE CONSCIOUS OF THE
FACT THAT IF THEY DO DO IT
AND ARE CAUGHT THIS IS GONNA
HAPPEN AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IN THIS PURPOSE
AND WITH ALL DUE RESPECT THE
OPPOSITION'S THERE'S NOT A
SINGLE VIOLATION OF THE VEHICLE
CODE WHERE YOU ONLY GET A
POINT AFTER A SECOND VIOLATION
THIS DEADLY ACTIVITY SHOULD BE
TREATED LIKE ALL OTHER MOVING
VIOLATIONS AND I FIRMLY BELIEVE
IF YOU KILL SOMEBODY SHOULD BE
CHARGED FOR MURDER MANSLAUGHTER
I'M HAPPY TO JOIN US FOR
THIS BILL WITH YOU IT WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL UNTIL IT
GOES TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
THANK YOU MISTER DALY HI LOU
DO HOPE THAT YOU CAN COME TO
A CONCLUSION MR DAILY IN AND
REMOVE YOUR OPPOSITION BECAUSE
I THINK THAT -- WE'VE TRIED
VERY HARD TO GET TO A POINT
ON THIS BILL OVER THE PAST
SIX YEARS THIS CLASS AND WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO FIND SOME
RESOLUTION AND UNDERSTAND
THE HIGHWAY PATROL TAXES
I WOULD PATROL
ASSOCIATION BACKS THIS
AND WANTS OUR HELP ALSO
AND WITH THAT'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL MISTER DAILY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
PLEASE CALL THANK YOU FOR
LIKE I AM I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER TO
MR YEAR CURRY -- MESSERVY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FRAZIER
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YEAR CURRY
I BERMAN BERMAN AYE BIGELOW
SURE -- I CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
AYE DALY DALY AYE DEEP DEEP
I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I GIPSON
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
MEDINA MEDINA AYE
NAZARIAN AYE NAZARIAN AYE
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL AYE
THE BILLS OUT THANK YOU
MISTER DEAL AND THANK
YOU TO ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE APPRECIATED
EXCUSE ME
A MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU
CAN PERCENT WE READY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR LET ME A PRESENT
TODAY AB THREE EIGHTY REMOVES
EXISTING TRANSPORTATION
INSPECTOR GENERAL FROM WITHIN
CALTRANS AND ESTABLISHES THE
POSITION AS AN INDEPENDENT
ENTITY WITHIN THE STATE
GOVERNMENT IT ALSO EXPANDS
EXPEND INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
RESPONSIBILITIES TO ENSURE
ALL ENTITIES RECEIVING STATE
OR FEDERAL TRANSPORTATION
FUNDS OR OPERATING EFFICIENTLY
EFFECTIVELY AND IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE LAW AS YOU KNOW
SB ONE INCLUDE A NUMBER OF
REFORM AND OVERSIGHT MEASURES
INCLUDING THE CREATION OF
THE INDEPENDENT OFFICE OF
AUDITS AND INVESTIGATIONS
WITHIN CALTRANS AND THE
POSITION OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
WELL THIS WAS A GOOD FIRST STEP
TOWARD OVERSIGHT IN THE STATE'S
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS IF
FALL SHORT OF THE COMPREHENSIVE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE ROUGHLY
TWENTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDING SPENT
ANNUALLY ON TRANSPORTATION IN
CALIFORNIA RECENT ACTIVITIES
RELATED TO STATE TRANSPORTATION
DEPARTMENTS OTHER THAN CALTRANS
DEMONSTRATE THE NEED FOR A
STATE WIDE TRANSPORTATION
INSPECTOR GENERAL EXAMPLES
ABOUT FROM THE MISMANAGEMENT
OF THE DEEP DMV'S ROLLOUT
OF REAL ID TO THE RECENT
REVELATIONS OF FRAUDULENT
BEHAVIOR BY OUR SEIZE P.
OFFICERS AND THERE IS THE
STATE'S AUDITOR'S FINDINGS
AT THAT HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITIES FLAWED DECISION
MAKING AND POOR CONTRACT
MANAGEMENT HAVE CONTRIBUTE TO
BE BILLIONS IN COST OVERRUNS
AND DELAYS THIS PROPOSAL IS
NOT UNIQUE THE US DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION HAS THIS
IS SIMILAR INDEPENDENT OFFICE
TO HOLD ENTITIES ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THE PROPER USE OF FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS IT'S
TIME FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO INSTITUTE TRUE OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FLOWING EACH YEAR INTO THE
DEVELOPMENT MAINTENANCE AND
ADMINISTRATION AND ENFORCEMENT
OF THE STATE'S TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK IN TRAFFIC SAFETY
LAWS AB THREE EIGHTY GRANTS
TO TRANSPORTATION INSPECTOR
GENERAL THE INDEPENDENCE NEEDED
TO ENSURE OUR TAX DOLLARS ARE
BEING USED EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
I THINK IT WAS GERMAN
ARE THERE ANY IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE THE ONE SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THINGS VICE YOUR KEEP DONE
HERE BEHALF THE SELF HELP
COUNTIES COALITION TWENTY FIVE
COUNTIES NOW THAT MAKE UP SALES
TAX -- INITIATIVES TO INVEST
IN OUR INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO WORK
WITH OUR GOOD FRIEND CHAIRMAN
FRAZIER TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE WILL OF THIS LEGISLATURE
WHICH BY TWO THIRDS MARGIN AND
THEN THE VOTERS ENFORCE THAT
ADDITIONALLY -- MORE THAN ONCE
THAT THESE DOLLARS GET INVESTED
IN OUR PRIORITY INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
-- INSPECTOR GENERAL TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS THE WILL OF
YOU HERE'S THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE VOTERS IS REINFORCED THOSE
MONIES ARE SPENT ACCORDINGLY
IS IMPORTANT STEP IN A GOOD
GOOD OVERSIGHT FOR THIS THOSE
INVESTMENTS OF THOSE FUNDS --
WE'RE IN SUPPORT I HAVE NOT
GOT A LETTER IN YET OUR BOARD
HAS NOT HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GET THAT DONE BUT WE WILL BE
-- MOVING FORWARD TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL -- THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS SO THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR ANY SEEING NINE
ANY ANYONE THE PUBLIC LIKE
SPEAKING OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE ANY MEMBER ANY MEMBERS
ON THE DÍAS ANY QUESTIONS
I WAS SURE I LIKE TO SAY THAT
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL
I PLEDGE LEADERSHIP ON THIS
YOU KNOW I'VE TALKED ABOUT
OVERSIGHT FOR A LONG TIME AND
I WOULD HOPE THAT YOU ALLOW
MYSELF AND OTHERS TO -- --
AT THAT TO TO SIGN ON AS CO
AUTHORS ABSOLUTELY THE --
ORDERED THANKS VERY MUCH --
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE DÍAS HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE CHAIRMAN IS MR CARE SO
THIS COMPONENT OF OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL WAS INITIALLY IN THE
ORIGINAL VERSION OF SB ONE
CAN AGAIN NEGOTIATED DOWN TO
WILL A SMALLER VERSION ONLY IN
CALTRANS BUT HOW EFFECTIVE BUT
IT'S BEEN IN CALTRANS ALONE IS
IMPRESSIVE AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE LEGISLATURE
TO ENFORCE ACCOUNTABILITY
EFFICIENCIES AND USING THE
TAXPAYERS' MONIES AS WIDELY
AS POSSIBLE ASK YOUR IPHONE
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER NAZARIAN A SECOND BY --
-- MACEO CURRY AMEND SECTOR --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW FRAZIER
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY HI BERMAN BERMAN
AYE BIGELOW CHAIR ARE YOU AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
DAILY DALY AYE DEEP HI
DEEP I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I
GIPSON -- GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
AND I MEDINA MEDINA AYE
NAZARIAN HI IS THERE AN AYE
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
IT WAS FOURTEEN
YEAH
SO WE WILL KNOW IF THE CALL
AT ALL MEASURES TO ALLOW THE
ABSENT MEMBERS TO RECORD VOCALS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AGUIAR-CURRY HI FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I MEDINA MEDINA AYE
THIS AREA AND I O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL AYE THAT HAS
FIFTEEN VOTES ON THE RULES
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I'M
MEDINA -- MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL THERE'S FIFTEEN VOTES
SO I JUST ON A. B.
FORTY SEVEN BIGELOW
GIPSON START HERE THAT
MEASURE HAS THIRTEEN VOTES
YEAH
ON ITEM SIX AB THREE SEVENTEEN
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I IS
THERE IN MISSOURI AND I THAT
MEASURE HAS FIFTEEN VOTES
ON AB THREE EIGHTY BIGELOW
THAT MEASURE HAS FOURTEEN BUT
SO THAT CONCLUDES THE
OF THE BUSINESS OF THE
COMMITTEE ABLE TO LEAVE THE
ROLE BUT A FEW MINUTES FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
ATTENDANCE AND -- LOOK FOR
TO OUR NEXT MEETING TOGETHER
THAT CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS
OF THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WE ARE GERMAN